hi everyone this is natural language
passwords recorded for Linux fest
Northwest 2020 this presentation is for
those who are interested in an
innovative approach to generating
memorable passwords passwords are a
daily part of life for anybody involved
in technology there are lock screens
online accounts and apps that all demand
that we create passwords and login
you've probably heard a lot of advice on
how to make a good password everyone
knows your password must be 8 characters
long and really you should include
numbers actually did I say 8 characters
better make that password 12 characters
long and use both upper and lowercase
letters of course and throw in some
symbols for good measure this is what a
lot of our passwords look like the
problem is that passwords like these
don't provide much security and worse
they provide an unmeasurable amount of
security maybe hackers will guess your
password and maybe they won't how can
you tell whether or not your password is
good enough most of the time people have
no idea at my organization all 500
employees use passwords that are about
30 characters long these passwords are
not just long but so random that it
would take decades to guess one you can
measure how strong these passwords are
without any complicated math and most
interesting thing is that these
passwords are pretty easy to remember I
call the system natural language
passwords in this video I'll describe
how you can use this same system to
create really great passwords I want to
see upfront though you should use this
system sparingly the idea isn't to
memorize dozens of 30 character
passwords
I recommend memorizing one password this
is the password that unlocks your
password manager then let the password
manager remember the rest of your
passwords for you I know this doesn't
work for everybody but personally I
don't want to have to remember a bunch
of passwords regardless for the
passwords you do need to commit to
memory natural language passwords will
make it as painless as possible while
maintaining the level of security that
you want now before we get too far I
want to briefly mention where this
system evolve from Arnold Reinhold
invented the dice where system about 25
years ago and dice were as this
Purab system for generating passwords
his website has a detailed explanation
but the original dice were suffered from
some quirks that have hampered
mainstream adoption and many people have
never heard of it let alone use it
recently the e FF made substantial
improvements to dice where this
revitalization of dice wear inspired me
to work on the system let's start at the
beginning and explore what makes a
password
useful for security passwords are
memorized secrets they give you access
to a system or information because you
know the secret and they prevent access
by those who do not know the secret in
order to do its job a memorized secret
must be difficult to guess what makes a
secret difficult to guess though let's
look at some padlocks and the basic math
that shows you how difficult a password
is to guess let's imagine using a
combination lock to secure your gym
locker what do you think about this one
in the corner this combination lock is
way too simple with only one dial to
turn it's obvious that there are only 10
possible combinations you could use to
lock it 0 through 9 if someone wanted to
open this lock but didn't know the
correct combination it would take a
maximum of 10 guesses to open the lock
but in reality the correct combination
would be guessed in about half that time
since it's not likely that it would take
all 10 guesses to stumble upon the
correct number there are a few ways to
make this lock more secure
we could opt for a lock with more dials
how much more secure is it multiply the
number of choices on the first style by
the number of choices on the second dial
and you get a maximum of 100 possible
combinations again someone purely
guessing would likely find the correct
combination after about half as many
guesses with only a hundred available
combinations and a successful guess
expected after only 50 it wouldn't take
very many tries to open this lock adding
a third dial means the number of
possibility rises to 10 times 10 times
10 or a thousand would this be secure
enough for your gym locker though if it
takes a thief 5 seconds to guess a
combination and we presume that the
correct combination will be guessed
after 500 attempts you would expect
protection for about 40 minutes it's
important to note that a thief might get
lucky and guess your combination on the
very first try but that's unlikely the
thief might also be terribly unlucky and
end up needing to try every single
combination only succeeding on the final
guess but that's also unlikely you
should assume that most of the time it
will take about half the maximum number
of possibilities and guesses maybe you
want to secure your gym locker for an
hour or two while you're working out and
40 minutes of protection doesn't cut it
the simplest way of increasing the
maximum number of possible combinations
is to continue adding dials with four
dials there are 10,000 possibilities our
hypothetical thief would likely need to
guess about five thousand times taking
far too long to open the locker this
lock should be good enough security not
by making the locker totally impossible
to open but by making the correct
combination too time-consuming to find
combination locks don't have to be
numeric if you had four dials each dial
sporting ten letters of the alphabet the
calculation works the same there would
be 10,000 possible combinations of those
letters if you had a large enough lock
with large enough dials you could fit a
whole alphabet on each dial we
four dials of 26 letters the lock would
offer nearly half a million possible
combinations notice that we now have two
methods of increasing the security of
the lock increase the number of
characters we can choose in other words
the size of the dial or increase the
number of times we choose meaning how
many dials are on the lock either method
will increase the maximum number of
possibilities and make it much harder
for the thief to guess the correct
combination the caveat here is that
these combinations must always be
completely random if you set your
combination to 1 2 3 4 or ABCD don't
expect much security those combinations
may be the first guesses a thief tries
the same math works just as well for
passwords as it does for combination
locks a four-letter password made up of
the 26 lowercase letters also offers the
same half a million possibilities adding
in uppercase letters doubles the number
of options on each dial so to speak and
look at the number of possible
combinations this password is now one of
seven million different possibilities we
could continue increasing the strength
of our password by adding in numerals
and symbols but there are only so many
keys on the keyboard that are easy to
type so let's just make the password
longer adding a 5th dial to this
password brings our maximum
possibilities up to 380 million now you
might wonder at this point if we've gone
a little bit too far who on earth would
have the patience to hunt through
millions and millions of possible
passwords just to find yours
well it turns out that computers are
very good at quickly guessing passwords
computers make good tools for hackers
who often want unauthorized access to
your systems and information guessing
your password can be an easy way to get
that unauthorized access a single home
PC for example can make 50 billion
guesses per second under the right
circumstances at that rate it will try
every combination possible for this 5
character password almost instantly
we have to continue lengthening our
password otherwise a hacker will guess
it quickly even at eight characters long
any password of just upper and lowercase
letters will be found in 18 minutes when
attacked at a rate of 50 billion guesses
per second in order to calculate the
time a hacker would need to guess one of
these passwords we need to know the
maximum number of possibilities if our
password is 8 characters long and each
character is selected from 52 letters we
do the multiplication 52 times 52 times
52 times 52 etc that's a lot of 52 s
though so the shorthand way of
expressing the same calculation is 52
raised to the power of 8 it means the
same thing anyway it's quite a lot of
possibilities 53,000 billion that is a
large number but we want to know how
long it would take to guess the correct
password so let's divide by the guessing
rate which is 50 billion guesses per
second for a single PC the result is the
number of seconds required to make every
possible guess in this case it would
take 1000 69 seconds or about 18 minutes
to try every combination of an eight
character alphabetic password because of
the very high rate of guessing a hacker
might use against your password
extremely high maximum possibilities are
required for security millions of
combinations aren't sufficient billions
aren't sufficient your password must be
a needle in a haystack of trillions upon
trillions of possible passwords so that
a hacker has a near zero likelihood of
guessing your password ok with that bit
of math out of the way we're well
prepared to make informed decisions
about your passwords you can calculate
how resistant a password will be to
guessing by dividing the maximum number
of possible passwords by the rate at
which a hacker will attempt to guess
your password this tells you the time an
attacker needs to successfully guess one
of your passwords you also know that in
reality it will likely only take half
that long I mentioned I swear earlier
dice ware has several excellent features
the first is that instead of assembling
a password from numbers letters or
symbols you use words this is analogous
to each dial on the combination lock
having a selection of words instead of a
selection of numbers and if each dial
offered a selection of 26 words these
two passwords would be equivalently
difficult to guess when logging in you
type a word based password as boat space
dog space pen space sky in practice this
is very natural people are accustomed to
typing words separated by spaces because
that's a sentence as natural rhythm and
even though word based passwords tend to
be longer you'll find that they're much
faster to type than a hodgepodge of
numbers letters and symbols coming back
to the calculation a selection of 26
words used four times is equivalent to a
selection of 26 letters used four times
in both cases there are nearly
half-a-million possibilities using words
can greatly increase our passwords
strength however while we're limited to
about 100 keys on a typical keyboard
most people no tens of thousands of
words for example assembling a password
using four words drawn from a list of
just 5,000 skyrockets the maximum
possible combinations to 625 trillion
the other aspect of dice where is that
the words are chosen randomly by rolling
six-sided dice like you'd find in a
board game or at a casino the outcome of
the dice rolls determines which words go
into your password this is an easy way
of ensuring that your password is random
which is necessary for security let's
say you roll some dice you roll for one
two five six you'd use a dice where word
list to look up the word that matches
that roll which happens to be the word
boat repeat another few times and you'll
have your password when rolling five six
sided dice there are 7776
outcomes possible at
six raised to the power of five if you
have your calculator handy dice we're
word lists are sized so that every
result of the dice roll is associated
with a unique word when rolling five
dice the word list contains 7776 words
which is how Arnold Reinholds original
dice wear is structured if we used a
word list designed for five dice to
create our password we use the standard
calculation to find the maximum number
of possibilities which is a staggering
3600 trillion combinations the e FF word
lists come in different sizes there are
the traditional five roll lists but also
smaller lists used with four dice which
contain twelve hundred and ninety-six
words if we use the smaller word list
designed for four dice the number of
possibilities is down to two trillion
you may wonder why not just use the
bigger list isn't that more secure hold
that thought we'll see why in a minute
we're coming around to what makes
natural language passwords different
from the original dice where the first
thing I realized was that I could use
lists of different sizes the first word
can be drawn from a small word list and
the second from a large word list
normally dice where passwords are
created from a single list of words
using different sizes of lists does
reduce the maximum number of possible
combinations to 100 trillion which isn't
as good as using the large word list for
each word but using different sized
lists allows us to do something clever
let's say your first word is drawn from
the small list you roll 4 dice and get 3
1 1 2 you look up 3 1 1 2 in the small
list and see that your first word is
blue you then roll 5 dice to produce the
second word and get 4 1 2 5 3 looking at
the large word list you find your second
word is Inc these two words form a pair
since the small list contains only ajik
and the large list contains only nouns
adjectives nouns reflect normal grammar
patterns which i think makes them easier
to memorize let's generate our second
pair of words you roll four dice and get
to five three three you look up to five
three three in the adjective list and
see that your first word is ugly you
next roll five dice and get six for six
to one looking at the noun list you find
your second word is bird these two words
form your second adjective noun pair
this password follows the adjective noun
adjective noun pattern our final
password is then blue ink ugly bird it's
one out of a hundred and one trillion
possible passwords as usual you type
each word separated by a space I find
that this style of password mimics our
natural language patterns when the
adjective and noun pair nicely they
become almost a single object so rather
than memorizing for unrelated words
you're memorizing two objects some blue
ink and an ugly bird a password like
this is suitable for online accounts
such as email and social media what I
mean is that at an expected guess rate
of 100,000 guesses per second the hacker
would spend an average of 16 years
before finding your password now
personally I think 100,000 guesses every
second is likely to be noticed and shut
down by an online service but it's nice
to know that even if an online service
allowed that kind of attack you're still
covered for a very long time die square
based systems like natural language
passwords are flexible there are
situations where 16 years of protection
just aren't needed on a home desktop
computer for example you don't need to
defend against someone making 100,000
guesses per second at your keyboard for
that scenario a single pair of words
should suffice
guessing a two-word password is still
quite difficult being one of 10 million
possibilities even if someone could try
one guess per second at your desktop
they would need an average of eight
weeks to find your password that's 24
hours a day seven days a week with no
sleep typing a guess every second on the
other hand there are situations where a
hacker may be able to guess at an
extremely high rate I mentioned a single
home PC guessing at 50 billion per
second but hackers have many computers
and combining their power makes them
guess faster for protecting your
password manager encrypted files and
other types of sensitive information I
recommend that you use a three pair
password six word natural language
passwords are randomly drawn from a
billion trillion possible other
passwords a password like the one shown
is expected to withstand a trillion
guesses per second for an average of 16
years you can use various password
lengths with the natural language
password system there are times when you
may want to use a pair of words two
pairs of words or three pairs of words
depending on the expected threat
to make your own password you'll need
some supplies you'll need at least one
die though having five is a little bit
quicker you'll also need the to natural
language password lists of words there's
an adjective list and a noun list I
recommend printing these out but if you
don't have a printer you can use the PDF
on your screen it's also handy to have a
pen and some scratch paper just to be
clear it's completely unnecessary to
keep these word lists a secret dice
where systems are secure
even when hackers are fully aware of
which lists of words you use to create
your password this is why you can use
lists of words that are publicly
available on the internet for practice
let's pretend that you're going to
subscribe to an email service
fortunately the email service doesn't
place any outdated constraints on the
complexity of your password it won't
force you to add uppercase letters
numbers or symbols you'll need a
password made of four words visit the
natural language passwords github page
to download both the adjective and noun
lists for the first word roll your die
it's best to roll it vigorously so that
it bounces around unpredictably simply
dropping the die on a table doesn't cut
it you can use a cup to shake your die
and then toss the die into a box
read the face-up number and write it
down on a piece of scratch paper repeat
rolling the die until you have four
numbers then look up the word in the
adjective list that matches this
four-digit number if you rolled six
three one two your word might be cool
now turn to the noun list and roll five
additional numbers if you rolled three
three five six to your word might be
pizza that's the first pair of words
repeat this process once more to get
your second pair of words don't be
tempted to choose words you prefer or
reorder them the security of the system
depends on having the dice and only the
dice choose the words
all right your password is ready to use
I recommend keeping the scratch paper
with you until you've reliably memorized
your password that may take weeks if
you're concerned that you might someday
forget the password store the scratch
paper and a safe otherwise destroy the
scratch paper once you've memorized your
password dice where systems usually
provide a printable word list this is
good for an individual who wants to
generate a password or two you don't
even need a computer just a few pieces
of paper and some dice but if you're a
programmer and want to incorporate the
system into your software you'll also
find a Maria DB database export of the
word lists in the github repository you
can use this database to filter the word
lists perhaps removing plural nouns so
that there's no confusion over whether a
password contained nice dog or nice dogs
a Python utility script is included that
will pull 1296 adjectives from the
database and associate those words with
diced roles
you're basically dynamically printing
the dice where word list you'll do the
same thing for the nouns I'll update the
database of words from time to time as I
refine it with the primary goal of
providing enough adjectives and nouns
but pair nicely together I'd like to
take a moment to speak philosophically
about passwords we have decades of
experience with passwords many best
practices enshrined in government
regulations have turned out to not work
so well
expecting users to remember random
strings of symbols just doesn't work
requiring password changes every 90 days
doesn't work NIST has recently done a
180 on most of the password requirements
that have been common wisdom for decades
the revised special publication goes
into all the details I'd like to go one
step further and suggest that users
should never select their own passwords
that's one of the elegant things about
dice where that the dice choose the
password authentication systems should
behave similarly when I sign up for an
online service the service should tell
me what my password will be
this means that the service must be able
to generate simple but secure passwords
and I think that natural language
passwords are a good candidate
Thank You Linux fest Northwest 2020 for
the opportunity to talk about this new
system
you